so the first 15 minutes of spider-man
across the spider verse has been shown
behind scenes and we have been given a
description for it so let's get into it
the film starts in gwen stacy's universe
earth 65 where gwen is having an awkward
conversation with a police officer
father who is hunting down spider woman
unaware that his target is his own
daughter but when the villainous vulture
breaks out and attacks new york when
swings into action knowing that the
police will be waiting for her after
subduing her father when takes on the
vulture but before vulture can deal the
finishing blow to gwen she is rescued by
spider-man 2099 while they fight vulture
together he reveals that the first
film's climactic battle with king ping
ripped open tears in the multiverse
allowing all sorts of villains to wreak
havoc fortunately the tears also allowed
for help from the other spiders
including spider woman of earth 404 who
helps the other two web slingers bring
down the vulture but that's not the end
of gwen's problem as the father corners
her and holds her at gunpoint accusing
her of killing her universe's peter
parker with no other choice gwen is
forced to unmask and pleads for him to
listen to her in a darkly coloured scene
heartbroken gwen's father moves forward
with the rest but the other two spiders
come in and subdue him leaving a tea
full grain with a multiverse jumper to
make her escape the film then
transitions to miles brooklyn where our
hero is running late for a meeting with
his parents and college counselor miles
wants to apply to columbia university's
physics program to work in a project
that could allow a multiverse jump in
possibly to find a way to see gwen again
unfortunately he is having a hard time
keeping his superhero secret from his
parents in the beginning to get
suspicious i should also note that
spider-man across the spider verse has
been delayed until june the 2nd 2023 but
it does make sense given that lord and
miller also revealed that this film will
have 240 characters and be set across
six different spider universes and this
film also has over a thousand animation
staffers working on it which i think is
actually a record for the most number of
animators working on a single film so
given this and given the description of
the opening scene i gotta say this film
is sounding really really good and i
think it'll be worth the wait and to be
honest the first spider-verse film is
probably one of my favorite spider-man
films and i know it is for other people
as well so i can excuse the delay for
the film if it means we're going to get
a better film overall which i think will
be the case anyway that out of the way
let me know in the comment section below
if you're excited for this film and what
do you think of this description and if
you haven't already please like and
subscribe to show your support thanks
for watching guys